no podía contar de cuanta edad, de cuanta edad.
Paz de noche, ¿sabe que es eso?
Mujeres y niños y viejos y jóvenes.
¿Usted cree que es verdad?
No sé.
O estoy soñando, o estoy en un sueño, no sé.
No llegó el momento.
Todas esas personas que no creen en Dios
están equivocadas.
Todas las personas que piensan que son vivos
y saben más que uno,
saben menos que otro.
Nosotros no sabemos nada.
Nosotros caminamos en este mundo ciego.
Que no se ríe uno cuando él va bien.
Que no llore mucho cuando él va malo.
Porque todos los tiempos no son iguales.
Yo tengo muchas cosas que declarar,
no por ley Talmud.
No quiero declararlo.
Tiene que declararla.
En ley de Talmud de Torah,
cuando tú haces besesa bien para la humanidad,
no va a declarar.
Quieres ser cerrado, besesa.
Cuando no es besesa,
es una gran cosa que usted hizo.
Este que va a oír esas palabras,
que sabe algo de Talmud,
me van a atender.
Porque no es eso.
Cuando usted hace besesa,
no quiere usted hablar de esto.
Cuando usted habla de eso,
ya no es besesa.
Yo no quiero nada decir
que yo hizo en mi mundo,
en mi vida.
Aquí es otra cosa diferente.
Usted lo puede hablar y va a seguir siendo besa.
Esto es como un documento
que es para que el mundo sepa.
El Papa II,
paisano mío,
dijo así,
que nosotros cristianos
tenemos mucho, mucho tiempo estudiar leyes
y toda religión, catolismo,
viene de judaísmo.
¿Sabes de eso?
Vamos a volver a Sobibor, señor Isaac.
Lo llamaron, lo llamó
uno de los oficiales a usted
y a su esposa, ¿no?
Y usted llamó a su esposa.
Eso fue el domingo.
¿Qué pasó?
Bueno.
Yo y mi señora
y con nosotros estaban dos jóvenes,
también, que salieron de allá.
¿Cómo salieron?
No puedo decir.
No lo sé.
Nos recaminamos
juntos
de Sobibor
para Crejo.
Cuando usted fue saliendo de Sobibor, ¿qué vio?
Vio otras cosas en Sobibor,
por donde pasó, el camino que pasó.
Vio a gente trabajando.
¿Qué más vio?
Ya vamos a terminar este casete.
Vamos a ir.
Vete, vete.
Nosotros recaminamos
en la línea de un tren.
Saliendo de allá, recaminamos yo con mi señora
y esas dos muchachas.
De repente, yo vi a Emilio, un polaco,
un trabajador que trabajaba conmigo en Cerrevera.
Entonces dijo a Emilio,
dígale a mi hermano
que yo estoy vivo
y me están llevando para Crejo.
Todo el mundo sabía de...
de... de...
de la construcción laga de Crejo.
Era muy conocido.
Allá entraron
y allá se terminó la vida.
Trabajando hasta el último momento.
Terminó la vida.
¿Cómo sabía usted que iba para Crejo?
¿Cómo sabía que iba para Crejo?
Virtualmente dijeron.
Virtualmente en la puerta avisaron.
Nosotros recaminábamos solos.
Pasamos otros kilómetros.
Era...
Saliendo por Sobibor,
¿qué más vio usted en Sobibor?
El cielo igual.
El mundo igual.
No eran gentes.
El único que yo encontró, ese polaco,
que caminó allá para donde recaminaba,
para donde recaminaba en dos años.
Pero otras edificaciones también vio.
Oye, oye.
Yo quiero decir, ¿no?
Pasaron ocho kilómetros.
Llevaron a un lado.
Era un terreno cercano.
Y eran artistas de húngaro.
Húngaros. Especial.
Cantaban, bailaban muy bien.
Muchachas jóvenes.
Preciosas.
Y eran poquito sopa.
Nosotros.
Sopita.
Conchas de trigo
con agua.
Decían a nosotros.
Medio hora.
Y caminaban.
Las otras...
Caminaban junto con nosotros.
¿Quiénes estaban caminando con ustedes?
¿Pero cómo se llamaban?
No sé.
Yo no podía preguntar,
y ellos no me podían contestar.
Cuando llegaron a la puerta
y entraron en Krihuv,
fue hace muchos años,
estaban
cuatro, o seis, o seis.
Y reconocieron
a estos dos muchachos
que ellos estaban
en Zubibor.
Esta era la segunda vez en Zubibor.
Y ellos estaban
allá en Concentración Laga.
Y huyeron de allá.
Yo no quiero
ver más de mi vida
como hicieron con esos dos muchachos.
Con palos mataron
y viven con ellos.
Ellos pidieron,
déme un tiro.
No.
Los perros,
ellos querían
matar a los perros con palos,
no con tiros.
Usted no vale que le demos un tiro
para usted.
Y mataron.
Presencia de las otras pisioneras.
Me dijeron así.
Ustedes deben entender.
Si ellos hacen eso,
en casa que nosotros
vamos a oír,
toca, mismo o muerto,
como oyeron a esos dos muchachos.
Presencia de las otras.
¿Pueden entender?
¿Usted entiende eso?
¿Usted cree en eso?
¿Sabía cómo se llamaban esos muchachos?
¿Eran polacos también?
No puedo decirlo. No sé.
No puedo decirlo.
O no dejaron hablar nada en camino.
El alemán no dejó una palabra
para hablar. Mudo.
Ellos no querían hablar.
Ellos no trataban
de hablar.
Crijo.
Aquí está hablando
Isaac Mayadais.
¿Qué pasó en Crijo?
Entramos en la puerta.
Llegaron por un local.
Vino un barbero.
Dijo, doctor, espérenme,
mi señora.
Dijo, espérenme, ya estamos.
¿Qué pasa?
Lizo.
¿Qué pasa? Lizo.
Ya era la tarde.
O a las seis.
Ya era comida, ¿no?
Ya no quería hablar
de comida.
Y...
el perro
no dormía aquí.
En el cementerio.
Nada abajo.
El perro
dormía en el cementerio.
¿Y la comida qué?
Ya estaba terminado.
A las seis.
Allá, mire, cuando el timbre tocó.